my family and I find ourselves in an  interesting situation can I help you  looking for John doesn't ya who's  looking for John Gottman the walls are  closing in on all sides we're fighting  to survive your father's ranch is in a  kingdom and he isn't a king your family  deserves to lose everything  our honest Valley understand war coming  you bet your ass it's coming  this is where change begins with new  partnerships they will pull you they  will twist you and tear you into tiny  pieces to beat her I have to attack him  I have to play dirty we're about to find  out how big a role you play in this  family son you understand what I'm  asking  loyalty morality not part of the  equation for you right now so far from  this place I don't think your factors  there at all  [Music]  this cannot be fixed  all the angels are gone son there's only  Devils left  [Music]  you